hey how you doing today folks today I
will continue my breakdown on the plot
leaked and we are currently on Episode
six right now which is the episode right
before the finale so I expect this to be
one of the explosive episodes for next
season
maybe even the best episode next season
and regardless how something you feel
about the plot leaked I think it's time
to start accepting it for what it is so
I'm no longer going to discuss each
episode as if it's true or false I'm
just going to break it down as if it's
going to happen at least until something
comes out that proves it to be false and
I know some of you don't want to hear
that but to me it all seems like it's
going to come true so I'm going to treat
it that way for now on and if you think
the plot link is fake then I don't even
know why you keep listening to these
videos so I will read the whole episode
then go back and break down each section
of it and I feel like I should mention
something because of some of the
comments that I've been getting when I
break down one of these episodes
sometimes I will speculate why some of
these things may be happening do not
assume that those are my predictions
when I discussed a plot leak I throw out
some possible scenarios for why these
things are taking place that does not
mean I am saying that these things are
going to happen this way for a fact I'm
just trying to have fun with this stuff
so you guys should too and if I feel
strongly about something you know if I
feel strong about a way something may
happen then I will make an individual
prediction video for that topic as I
have done in the past so when I break
down this episode I will just store out
some ideas out there about why some
things may be taking place things that I
think of as I'm reading it just to start
a discussion with you guys it doesn't
necessarily mean that's how I think it's
going to play out I'm just giving you
guys some possibilities and if you think
they sound ridiculous then you must not
be watching the same show as me because
things have been ridiculous on this show
for quite some time so don't take things
so seriously all the time and I'm only
talking to like five people not everyone
most of you know how to have a good time
with it and for that I thank you I do
this because I enjoy it and I have fun
watching this show and I enjoy talking
to you guys I'm not doing this because
I'm making money off of this stuff so
just try to relax and have some fun with
it but anyways let's begin episode 6
John arrives at eastwatch-by-the-sea the
easternmost night
watch castle apparently torment had the
Brotherhood without banners member
locked in the jail the Brotherhood
without banners are on a mission from
the Lord of Light to fight the White
Walkers John leads a small force which
includes beric Dondarrion Thor Samir
tormund Giantsbane Jorah Mormont and
ginjury I'll call him Gendry Baratheon
the team is attacked by the night's king
army including a zombie polar bear which
kills Thor's of mirror they get
surrounded on a frozen lake nearly about
to be defeated but then Danny arrives
with their dragons she flies most of the
team back to safety but leaves Jon
behind apparently the night's king is
able to kill her dragon of this Ariane
and was erected as his own zombie dragon
jon is almost killed by the encroaching
hordes but then benjin swoops in to save
him he sends the wounded John off on his
horse before benjin is swarmed and
presumably killed by the whites at some
point in the episode John promises to
Dany to lay down his title as king in
the north
if Danny helps them against the White
Walkers ok so let's go back to the
beginning and start breaking down each
section of this stuff it says John
arrives at eastwatch-by-the-sea
apparently tormund had a member of the
Brotherhood without banners locked in
the jail the Brotherhood without banners
were on a mission from the Lord of Light
to fight the white walkers and first off
I just want to say thankfully there are
other people out there ready to fight
the white walkers I don't know what some
of you think of the Brotherhood but at
least they are willing to take the fight
to them and not just sit around waiting
for the white walkers to attack them the
Brotherhood certainly doesn't have the
weapons or manpower to defeat them but I
at least respect them for trying and at
first I thought maybe this was another
one of those rogue group of Brotherhood
without banners
like the one that attacked and
slaughtered all the people that the
Hound was working with but since we know
Thoris and beric Dondarrion go with Jon
north of the wall this must be them and
I wonder if this means torment had them
locked in the jail at the Nights Watch
castle at eastwatch-by-the-sea or if
torment is still when the Winterfell and
has them locked up there because the
last time we saw torment he was at
Winterfell and the leak has yet to say
anything about him until now so I wonder
if Jon Poorman
to meet him there or if John sent men to
protect each castle from the White
Walkers John must have kept most of his
men up north to guard it while he went
to speak to Daenerys so what do you guys
think about that what do you think about
torment having this guy locked up
I wonder if tor men would have locked
one of the Brotherhood without banners
members up do you think they were trying
to steal weapons or food or horses from
the Nights Watch for their mission or do
you think it's possible Arya could have
told everyone up there about barrack and
Thoros selling ginjury off to Melisandre
to be sacrificed or maybe tormund just
didn't want them crossing the wall yet
and they refused to wait so he locked
one of them up and maybe when John gets
there he offers the freedom you know if
he goes on his mission with them north
of the wall so let me know how you guys
see that playing out but let's move on
it says John leads a small force which
includes beric Dondarrion Thor Samir
tormund Giantsbane Jorah Mormont and
gantry Baratheon the team is attacked by
the night's king army including a zombie
polar bear which kills Thor Samir and
trust me I know ginjuries last name
isn't Baratheon but that's just what I'm
going to call him
it says they get surrounded on a frozen
lake nearly about to be defeated but
then Danny arrives with her dragons she
flies most of the team back to safety
but leaves Jon behind apparently the
night's king is able to kill her dragon
of its Ariane and resurrect it as its
own zombie dragon now personally I think
this is going to be insane I know most
of you hate this scene but I can't
freakin wait to see his long be dragon
this is definitely going to change
things in the show and change the power
dynamic and I'm still wondering why Jon
chose such an odd group to go with him I
really don't care why I like all these
characters regardless and I think it's
going to be fun to hear the dialogue
between them all but I'm just curious as
to why he chose these people to go with
him I'm really curious about that I
definitely understand why he would take
torment in my opinion he's John's
toughest soldier and certainly the most
experienced north of the wall Poorman
should know his way around up there and
be able to help them stay under the
radar as they move around trying to find
these whites and I also
like this is could be the night's king
setting a trap I think he may know
John's coming and he leaves some bait
out for him then pounces at the right
moment only he isn't going to expect
three big guys dragons to show up and I
can't wait to see the look on John's
face when he sees the night's king again
as if you remember at hardhome they had
that epic stare down and when I first
saw that scene I knew that there'd be
some payoff from that scene at some
point later on so I definitely think
we're really going to see that and if
you thought John looks stunned when the
night's king raised the dead at hardhome
wait until they see him take over this
dragon I think they're going to [ __ ]
their pants but what I'm really curious
is I wonder how Dany is going to react
when she loses one of her babies
Dany might say screw the Iron Throne for
now I want to kill this son of a [ __ ]
that took my dragon and John I'm sorry
for doubting you but now let's regroup
and get all of our forces together and
kill this bastard
I may never get this Ariane back but
it's time to make a statement and anyone
that comes from me or my dragons will
feel my wrath when Danny loses our
dragon I expect her to be ready to
retaliate with her full force and I
think it should be pretty damn epic when
that finally does happen I think that
episode could cost like 50 million
dollars and it'd be worth every penny
but I wonder why she rescues everyone
but leaves Jon behind I know Jon would
be the sole reason why she'd want to go
and see what the hell is going on north
of the wall anyway so I'm wondering what
makes her leave him there I'm thinking
he must be surrounded on its lake by all
the whites and there's no way for her to
torch all of them without killing Jon
who's probably going to be in the middle
of all these whites because it says Jon
is almost killed but benjin swoops in to
save him then he puts Jon on his horse
so he can escape but benjin gets swarmed
and presumably killed by the whites I
think if this does happen I still think
we are going to see uncle Benjen again
in the show but next time he's going to
be a 100% white and we may even see a
scene to where Jon or one of the Starks
have to kill Uncle Benjen even though
they won't want to but they're going to
have to and I wonder how Jon gets the
white out of there like when he catches
this white how is he planning on getting
it back south of the wall
because I doubt one of Danny's dragons
are going to allow one of these whites
to get on its back but for some reason I
just been picturing John tying this
weight up and just dragging it behind
the horse but give me your guys's
thoughts on that and the last part of
this episode says John promises to Danny
to lay down his title as king of the
north if she helps fight against the
white walkers I'm thinking this happens
early in the episode I'm thinking John
offers to lay down his title but Danny
is probably still not sure whether to
believe the threat or not but sometime
after John leaves for the wall that's
probably when she realizes well if he is
willing to give up his title he must be
pretty damn serious about this and
that's probably when she decides to go
help and shows up just in time and I
only say that because I doubt John would
still have to beg for help after she
loses a dragon I think there would be no
reason to try and convince her after
that
unless of course Danny is scared to lose
more dragons then maybe he'd have to
still try and convince her but I think
once she loses a dragon she's going to
be pretty damn pissed and ready to go to
war so give me your thoughts on this
episode please why do you think torment
had to lock up one of the Brotherhood
without banners members why do you think
John goes on his mission with this
specific team and how do you think the
night's king is able to get the dragon
like what type of power move do you
think he makes to take it out of the sky
like that's what I'm really curious
about and do you think we're going to
see uncle Benjen again if he does get
attacked and swarm by the whites do you
think we'll see him again later on as a
full white let me know what you guys
think about this stuff and I appreciate
you guys for listening as always the
loyal supporters who's always watching
every video thanks a lot guys I
appreciate that and I will see you next
time bye